hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on for our Megan for another
dead stream recap like we always do on
every Thursday but I just want to make
light of this really quick situation
I've been getting a fuckload of comments
for some reason in the past couple days
about how people assuming that I'm
leaving for honor which is entirely not
the case I uploaded a video on this
thing last week about the new arena mode
possibly coming soon in the next patch
and stuff like that and people are still
thinking that I'm leaving the game just
because I posted two to three videos a
fortnight in between then I have made it
publicly clear that I'm sticking with
for honor until this game refuses to
update anymore which is probably not
going to be for another couple years
which is amazing because I love this
game on top of that I'm always posting
the Monster Hunter stuff whenever they
come up with updates and I've been
recently getting into fortnight and I've
been enjoying that game a lot since I've
had a lot of friends play with me during
squads it just it seems like people are
putting words in my mouth when I read
these comments assuming that I'm not
playing for honor anymore and I've just
entirely dropped the game because I
don't upload a video even though I
uploaded one last week although to be
fair not many people probably did see
that video since there wasn't much news
but either way I do apologize for this
weird type of intro if you do want to
watch my other content that's fine if
you don't and you're only here for the
foreigner stuff or anything like that
that is completely fine as well I just
want to let everybody know that I'm not
stopping for on earth like I said until
this game stops updating which probably
won't be for another couple years or so
and I'll probably still continue on
after that so just want to make light of
that situation since but it's just been
frustrating me all week so I do
apologize for that
well regardless let's get into the news
today starting off with the news today
there wasn't really much to talk about
there was a few things worth noting but
nothing too crazy most of it was a lot
of questions so we'll get into that real
quick but there's going to be a 30% off
discount on steal packs from now until
April 3rd if you want to get those as
well as a new community event called
vanquish or rush be the first faction to
win the highest amount of matches in a
given time frame first team to win we'll
get steel crates and rewards and all
that good stuff so definitely if you
want to get some extra stuff definitely
participate this weekend in the
community event there was new battle
outfits called [ __ ] circuit splatter
star and solar champion they are battle
outfits I don't really feel like showing
them they're really aren't they really
aren't that great or really important
I'm not big on battle outfits myself
maybe you are but
are in the shop at the moment if you do
want to grab those next up they talked
about Q&A stuff in terms of questions
there wasn't really a lot like I said to
talk about on the dev stream so the the
devs asked the throwing your questions
will answer them and then will put them
up
the most important ones and then the
most important ones that were worth
noting was a question about hero reworks
coming and if there are any new heroes
coming or any of that good stuff and the
quite and the answer to that was can't
tell us new reworks are happening though
maybe not in the same number as season
five might be lower number don't know
when we'll disclose it in a few weeks
hopefully which is nice because that
means I get to have something to talk
about other than just random news that
comes up but yes there is supposed to be
some hero reworks this was definitely
talked about before in the past couple
weeks personally I really do hope that
they take care of the main priority
characters like Valkyrie in Orochi and
then moving on to the other characters
that still need it but not as much as
those two next question was about
getting entirely different armor as you
know most of the armor and forerunner
can be found at any type of level
throughout the game it just has that
better stats depending on which a rarity
it is so the in terms of adding entirely
true new armor let's say that there's
like an intent like just a strict armor
for the teal rank the very highest
portion of ranking that you can get for
your character
maybe there's that type of armor and
they said that they previously discussed
this on the Warriors then it's super
costly to make armor especially because
they have to make one for every single
hero I'll never say never but there's a
reason we have been started chipping
these every single season and it doesn't
make sense a lot of these cost a lot of
time to make especially since they have
to make everyone happy and give every
single hero one and then they might have
to make a couple more sets just in case
people don't like those so it does take
a lot of time to make these the next
three questions we're talking about a
new patch and when that's supposed to
come out and the next patch is for sure
going to be in April they said even
though it is almost April on a couple
days they did say it's not going to be
the end probably toward the middle I'm
going to assume since I said it's less
than a month this patch I'm assuming is
going to be coming with the arena mode
and the training trials like they talked
about a couple of weeks ago which is
really nice and maybe some hero reworks
who knows but then the next question was
talking about well every single hero get
a rework and they said that probably not
but they're going to be doing a priority
list to see which ones need it the most
and I'm like I said before I've
personally my priority list my top three
are
career row chunchu goki those three guys
needed the most to me as my opinion I
want to know what you guys think of the
comments below who you guys think needs
it the most and then the next question
was will there be a year to season pass
and they said not yet it's not that
we'll never do a season pass just not
now
so yes there's probably going to be a
year to season pass I'm assuming when
the year two characters dropped
technically this is year two but they're
technically it kind of wasn't because
there was no new heroes so I'm assuming
the next four seasons were going to
beginning so season six seven eight and
nine are probably going to consist of
new heroes or something along those
lines maybe just six seven and eight I
have absolutely no clue but we're
probably going to have to pay a season
pass to get those heroes since obviously
companies have to make their money of
course the rest of the questions were
just random shits and giggles for
comments talking to the devs about their
personal life and what they like just
not nothing regarding the game so it
wasn't really that important but now
like last week since there wasn't much I
want to talk about a discussion with you
guys and then kind of make our own
little discussion in the comments and
the two questions I want to ask are what
do you want to see in season six of in
terms of heroes new weapons new armor
certain specific things like maybe more
dual Maps or this and that and then what
changes would you make to for honor if
you were one of the main developers like
if you could just snap your fingers and
a type of change would come to the game
immediately what would it be I'd love to
know your thoughts but like I said there
wasn't much to talk about so that's
going to be the end of the video today
guys
once again I have to apologize for the
bit in the very beginning the intro but
I just had to get that off my chest
since a lot of people seem to be
confused so I just wanted to make that
official there I am not stopping for
honor crew because I wouldn't be making
this video if I was but either way like
the video if you guys did enjoy I
appreciate it a lot if you would
subscribe if you're new I cover a lot of
four on our news leaks discussions all
that good stuff the informational side I
like the cover on for honor my two
newest videos are gonna be on screen if
you guys do want to check that out and
with that guys hope you have a great
yesterday and peace out